Well,
your,
your concern is anti aging.
You certainly want people to live longer,
but you yourself are more concerned with
your work than you are with your own
personal life. Oh, 100%. My
wife will tell you that. Um,
the reason that I look off to myself as
best I can when I've got the energy is,
um, it would be a bad look if I died
from heart disease tomorrow. Yes.
The anti-aging guy. Well, if you died
from anything other than an accident,
right? Yeah. All right. So I'm trying
to be a role model for others. Um,
but you know, I, if I, if I died
tomorrow, that'd be fine with me.
I'd like to finish my work at least, uh,
I would like to leave something behind.
But what I don't want to do is to be
a burden on my kids and my grandkids.
Yeah. And so that's what I'm
also trying to prevent. Yeah.
That would seem to me to be the real
final frontier of anti-aging is folks that
are really,
really old because it seems like they
would be open to try almost anything.
And if you could bring them back,
that would be Uber bizarre.
Right. How far away do you think we are
from doing something like that? While it,
it often comes as a shock to people who
don't work on this that we're already
testing these molecules in
clinical trials on elderly people.
I've been doing that for a number of years
now, um, with some positive results. Um,
over at Harvard we were
getting any man and,
and another molecule called MIT be
66. Um, what's the other one called?
My laundry list so that the company's
called Metro Biotech and uh,
it makes Super Nad boosters and the
drug is called developmental drug is MIB
dash six two six six two
six. Yeah. And we're,
we're hoping that it will not just
of g of that alleyway somewhere. Ah,
or of that I got to go to some shady
doctor with a weird accent. Uh,
that one, uh, that one we hope to
get on the market in about, uh,
three years from now. Really? Yeah.
Foot for diseases, FDA approved.
And so they're using it right now on
old folks are testing it for safety.
Yeah. But we're also going to be
testing later, uh, energy. Uh,
we can measure actually the Nad
levels, that molecule I mentioned. Um,
we can measure that in their muscles and
we'll test if that worked. Um, and we'll,
we'll measure of course their insurance
because at the mice that we traded with
Nmn, uh, they just ran and ran and ran.
They actually broke the little treadmill
in my lab because they ran so far.
And you're giving it to them orally or
you're injecting it to them? Uh, it's a,
it's a little tablet.
They just put food,
put it in their food or something
like that. All the mice. Yeah. Oh No,
I thought you're talking about humans.
Uh,
in the mice we put in their drinking
water, Haley's trinkets, early easy. Wow.
And they have no idea. No idea. Um,
and in fact that people who are running
the treadmill have no idea which is
which,
but we had mice running three kilometers
and then the machine stopped and I get
a text from the researcher, Hey,
the machine broke. And I said, uh,
check the software.
And turns out software was written to
stop at three kilometers cause no mouse
had run that far before. That's long.
And those are old mice. Don't forget,
these are mice that equivalent or the
equivalent of a 65 year old human. Really?
Yeah. And we figured out why they
run further. This isn't just, uh,
try it and see.
We figured out that,
that the lining of the blood
vessels needs nad as you get older.
Well they need it all the time, but as
you get older you don't have enough nad.
So the Nmn replenishes that and allows
the blood vessel lining to respond to
exercise, um, and even grow blood vessels
if you don't exercise. And so those mice,
they ran and ran around,
they didn't get lactate build up as much.
I just didn't feel tired. So in that
lactic acid buildup, right. Wow.
So muscle fatigue would be different.
Uh,
well they didn't seem to get that either.
Wow. Is the just better blood flow?
We even pinched off an artery,
uh,
and the body responded much better
to restate restoring blood flow,
which would be great for patients
who have a heart attack. Whoa.
Now with human beings,
what has been the most dramatic result?
Uh, that's a hard question because
a lot of its early stage, um,
we developed a molecule that,
uh,
seem to effectively treat a disease
called psoriasis, which is the,
yeah. How's that? Yeah. So that, that,
that worked and that's a molecule.
That's something you apply to the skin. It
was a, it was a pill actually. Hmm. Yeah.
Um, how does that work?
What does it doing? A,
so it's an activator of one of these
[inaudible] are two ones that we found in
yeast originally.
These are two and protective enzymes in
the body and there are antiinflammatory
and so that worked well
against that disease.
So psoriasis has something
to do with inflammation.
It isn't an inflammatory
disorder. Yup. Um,
are all autoimmune disorders anti
inflammatory based disorders?
I believe so. Really? Interesting.
Huh?
Cause I have a,
I have Videle ego.
You don't see that little spots on my
skin where I don't have a, any pigment,
it's genetic. My grandmother had it.
My grandmother sister had it. Um,
I wonder if that would help me. Uh, yeah.
I really couldn't say. What's
it called again? Which one?
The drug that was tested.
Yeah. Um, it has a name, s, r t 2104.
And this is the stuff that
worked on psoriasis. Yeah.
In a small study in New York.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Now what other,
um,
what other things had really a
dramatic results on humans? Well,
we're not there yet.
We don't have dramatic results.
Is there anything promising results
on humans or then NMN and yes,
there are there. So this
m tore I mentioned earlier
where, uh, the drug rapamycin,
which is too dangerous,
try on normal people. Um,
that drug has been tried on elderly people
and it boosted their immune system in
the same way that you see with
calorie restricted mice. And so that,
that was an early signal that you might
be able to reverse aspects of aging and
the elderly with that truck.